alors ophélie qu'est-ce qui se passerait
si vous posiez 30 kg de plus j'en sais
rien on va le savoir
alterview 30 kg + réfugiés 30 kg de plus
vous passeriez combiné dames sacré
métier passeriez combien
soixante dix 70 ouais ouais c'est pas
loin de 40 kg 1
suivront les chais compter ses formes
c'est vrai nom est ce que vous feriez un
régime si vous posiez de trompes tu veux
plus non parce que si je faisais 30
qu'il vous plaît je pense que j'aurai
des raisons ouais donc j'en ai rien à
[ __ ] je riais quel métier si vous
posiez tranquille le plus indécent de
musique j'aurai un gros cigare dans un
fauteuil en cuir elle enverrait des gens
entière tapinage travailler à votre
place
est ce que vous seriez plus heureux si
vous posiez 30 kg de plus
non je pense pas non non vous seriez
plus grosses bonnes questions la bonne
réponse est jolie l'arrêté strict des
ministres au fait si vous pouviez
prendre qu'il veut plus est ce que vous
pensez que votre mec aurait vu votre
beauté intérieure derrière vos
bourrelets
j'espère que oui sinon c'est grave mais
il vous aimerez pareil et je sais pas
j'espère que j'en ai maintenant un
magnéto avec le voilà
ah si vous posiez 30 kg le plus c'est ce
que vous couriez le premier soir ah non
je serai super complexé mais on couche
pas le premier sort quoi qu'il arrive
quoi qu'il arrive mario bros voilà
d'accord si vous posiez se rendre qu'il
veut plus vous feriez l'amour dans
quelle position dans le noir et sur le
dos comme ça comme moi aucune winters si
vous posiez 30 kg ou plus
est-ce que j'aurais une chance avec vous
je pense que j'aurai tellement
désespérée que oui c'est méchant
moi
si françoise peser 30 kg de plus
l'accueil en mairie
la question était intéressant on irait
doucement vers le plateau nique jeux
près je suis et je suis très sensible
aux apparences